every year we make a video of the Nobel
Prize in Chemistry on the day that it is
announced months in advance
I tell Brady not only the day but even
the time so he should put it in his
diary and this year he suddenly
announced sorry I've got to be an
American that day and I was really
crossed there I was sitting in front of
the computer seeing who was going to win
not a sign of Brady or the camera I'm
sorry I'm so sorry anyway rather later
than usual we're making a video about
this year's Nobel Prize and we've got to
make the video we want to have a
complete set so that you know what all
the prizes are about so this prize was
given to three so called theoretical
chemists or computational chemists who
don't do experiments but do calculations
on computers to help understanding of
chemistry for the development of multi
scale models for complex chemical
systems that probably doesn't mean very
much to but first I tell you their names
there are three chemists all working in
the United States
Martin Karplus Michel Levitt and a real
world shell now let me explain what they
did or at least give you a flavor I'm
not a computational chemist I've never
done any computational chemistry so this
is a personal and enormous Lee
simplified view when people first
started doing calculations about
molecules they imagined the molecules as
um heavy atoms joined together literally
by Springs and you just calculate for
example how these vibrate just in the
same way as you do the calculation for
this model now the problem with this is
that the really interesting things about
molecules is how they react and the
reactions of molecules are
not totally but largely determined by
how the electrons move around along the
bonds inside the molecule or even move
from one molecule to another and if you
do calculations about electrons you
can't treat them just like bulls and
Springs but you have to use so-called
quantum mechanics which treats the
electrons as waves you might ask well
what's the problem and the problem is
that quantum mechanical calculations
require a large amount of computing time
and the more atoms you have the more
computing time it gets bigger and bigger
and bigger the difficulty is that
especially at the time when these
chemists started working together or at
least in the same field was that people
were really interested about large
biological molecules which might have
10,000 atoms in it the idea of doing the
calculation on the molecule that size
was far beyond what computers can even
do today let alone 40 years ago so their
real innovation was to realize that the
chemistry in these large molecules often
takes place in quite a small volume of
the big molecule you can see this in our
video about hemoglobin for example where
all the action takes place around the
iron atoms in hemoglobin and the rest of
the protein is just there to keep the
various iron parts in the right places
the idea that they hit on was that you
could use quantum mechanics for the
really important bits and you could use
the classical mechanics that is bulls
and springs idea for the parts of the
molecule that are a long way away and
where the electrons behavior is not
important and they suddenly opened up
huge understanding of the behavior of
large molecules and has been very
important in explaining to people how
these large biological molecules occur
and if you like bringing this much
closer to understanding what is the
chemical basis of life I think that this
is a very nice nobel prize in the sense
that it's a huge intellectual
achievement and it applies to a vast
range of different sorts of compounds
just after the prize was announced
friend of mine sent me an article
written by Michael Levitt one of the
three Nobel Prize winners about how
Michael Levitt at the age of 19 applied
to be a PhD student of postgraduate
students at the very famous laboratory
of molecular biology in Cambridge and
what is really interesting in this story
is that the young Michael Levitt was in
fact told that he was too young and he
should go away for a year and work in
Israel and he really didn't want to but
he was finally persuaded and he went to
work in the lab or into the department
of area war so the person that he has
now shared the Nobel Prize with
and what they think of the Nobel Prize
and I should show you the other side as
well it's rather nice and it has a very
nice red leather case but I haven't
brought that because it doesn't fit in
my pocket